and yeah so the last speaker of the
session and the last week of the day is
uh joran yang and he's going to be
talking about sequential information
design so
let's uh yeah again i'll let you take it
away if you're okay ready to go yeah
great thank you thank you dylan for the
introduction and thank you for the
invitation uh it's my good great
pleasure to be here and today i'm going
to talk about our recent work on
information design or in other words
basic persuasion and this is joined to
work with uh jiban
who is a phd student at
bridge at virginia
and zuzuan who is a undergrad at
ustc and draw from google and jaron from
northwestern and mike jordan from
berkeley and hyphen from
from virginia
and
my talk will be divided into three parts
i will first talk about uh
briefly motivate the problem and then i
will talk about our new model which is
called markov markup persuasion process
and which is a
a model about a sequential version of
bayesian persuasion and finally i will
introduce the algorithm for solving this
problem when we don't know when we don't
know
uh when we don't know the model and need
to estimate uh learn how to
persuade uh yeah online fashion from
data
so first i will talk about the
uh
motivating uh talk about a
simplified motivating example just
consider uh a
right-handing system where a customer p
uh wants to uh wants to take a ride
and she is in a remote area let's say at
berkeley hill
and then
this is uh he's in the mountain and
there are no available drivers nearby
and
then to serve
this customer
the platform would like to encourage
available drivers in in distant areas
say in san francisco to come to berkeley
to pick her up
but that available to that available
driver might prefer to stay at san
francisco because they are there might
be more opportunities
and
that driver might be willing to wait for
a bit even if
she is available right now she might
prefer to wait at san francisco for for
other customers and and and serve them
so the only way that we can the the
platform can incentivize this driver to
to drive all the way from san francisco
to berkeley hill to pick up that
passenger uh and say to uh to give that
driver a better play a better pay say
getting a better tip then our simplified
this simplified example assumes that the
customer the the passenger are divided
into two types
one type is called good tipper who are
very generous about tipping and another
type is called bad slipper who are not
then the driver is only we assume that
the driver is only waiting to come from
all the way from from san francisco to
berkeley if the driver uh if the car if
the passenger is a good tipper
now uh
for this for this setting uh the the
driver and the platform have misaligned
objectives for the driver
she wants to have better have good tips
so she only wants to come to berkeley to
pick up the passenger if if she gets
good tip
but for the platform she won the
platform wants to serve the passenger to
because the the platform is essentially
a matchmaker and the platform
gets service fee if if the passenger and
the driver are matched
then for this problem
there's an information advantage because
the platform knows exactly
whether p is good or bad tipper but the
driver only have a prior distribution
about the
about the type of
the passenger and for simplicity we
assume that the the prior probability of
a good taper is one one third and the
bad taper is two thirds
then uh the platform might be willing
might be sending a signal to incentivize
the driver
to come to berkeley and pick up the the
passenger and the signal here we assume
is just a rating say
rate the passenger as a good good tipper
or bad tipper
and the the passenger the platform might
be able to send such a signal
uh to the to the to the driver in order
to incentivize to maximize the
platform's utility which is the
probability that
the driver and the patenter are matched
or in other words the driver comes to
berkeley to pick up the passenger
then how do we signal a rational driver
there are a few strategies the first one
is
to always signal good
or always signal bad it makes no
difference then such a signal has no
information
because uh if the if the driver computes
the posterior the posterior is equal to
the prior then based on the prior
distribution in our previous slide um
here the
the probability that the bad t the
better is larger than the probability of
good cheaper then
based on this prior which is equal to
the posterior the driver will not come
so in other words there is no service so
the utility for the platform is zero
now consider
a second strategy
which uh
in which the
platform truthfully reports the type of
the
customer that is if the customer is
indeed a good tipper then the signal is
g otherwise the signal is
sb then uh from the perspective of the
dryer of the driver the optimal way is
to just follow follow directly the
signal
that is if the if the driver if the
driver sees g then she will come
come to berkeley and pick up and
otherwise
she will just stay at san francisco and
choose not to not to pick up then
utility is just equal to one-thirds
so
is it possible that we can do better uh
actually
there is a way to do better that is to
send noisy information or
we can randomize the signal
let's suppose we send signal in in this
fashion this
gt means a good tipper bt means bit uh
bad tipper
and i have a figure showing this policy
yeah
sorry
about doing better you mean doing better
from the platform's perspective at the
driver's expense right so the driver is
going to end up being exploited by uber
and more frequently pick up the people
who don't get it right
not necessarily because
it might also benefit the the driver
because the driver might have better
tips
and
is that changing the example is
um
so the driver doesn't know exactly what
what the passenger is right
yeah
isn't strategy 2 optimal for the driver
optional for the driver
it is optional for the driver
given the uh
given given this signaling scheme
because when you compute the posterior
distribution uh it turns out that
following the signal is optional for the
driver
is there any other scheme that the
driver would like better than this one
i'm not sure no no you cannot do better
than trafficking that's
imagine that's the yeah that's the best
of
uh
diversity with consumer utility they are
doing this yes
so it's
better for the perspective from the
perspective of of the cost of the
platform
but it depends on the platform objective
so you know if the platform is all about
pleasing drivers then you know
full information it's
not bad but maybe the platform is trying
to balance you know strike a balance
between the interests of these two
groups and then that case
you might want to
right uh please more the customers and
that's the drivers yeah yeah i wasn't
trying to get into the debate i'm just
trying to understand what the notion of
that is also here the platform's goal is
to maximize the probability of
of the service
this is the
youtube oh i think it's in
here for example that might not be like
x post individual rational for the
drivers i think the driver is going to
be sort of
happy on expectation but like a lot of
the time in the realization they're
going to they're going to [ __ ]
yes yes exactly because the driver
doesn't know whether p is good or bad
yeah this is the information the
asymmetry
thank you
so can we do that what i mean is can the
platform do better achieving a higher
ratio than one-thirds or
and it turns out that uh sending a
randomized signal uh is better for the
for the from the perspective of platform
uh
let's say uh if
if the the so the platform knows exactly
whether ph is a good tipper or bad
tipper so if if fp is good tipper then
uh the platform will always signal g
and otherwise uh with probability
slightly slower smaller than one half it
will uh
it will signal g and with probability
slightly above one half it will signal b
and this is given by by this figure then
we can given this we can compute the
posterior distribution
uh
upon receiving a signal whether it's g
or b so if the signal is g then the
posterior distribution for
for a good taper is
is actually slightly above one half
and uh so given uh conditioning on the
on the signal g the posterior
distribution of
uh
of the belt tipper is slightly
below one half in other words uh if the
if the driver sees a signal g
then it's actually better off for the
driver to pick uh to pick up the
passenger because it has a better uh
posterior posterior utility for the for
the
from the perspective of the driver
then uh in other words this driver takes
uh takes order if and only if this
condition holds but if the if the driver
sees uh signal b
then definitely the driver knows that
the
it's a bad tipper
so she will not come
and
um
so
for this signaling scheme the option was
the optional policy for the driver
uh is to
always take the order if if it sees if
she sees the signal g then with this
signaling scheme the utility is equal to
the probability of of signaling a signal
g comes uh shows up in the system which
is about one-thirds uh about two-thirds
so one-thirds of this probability come
to
from this this channel and the other one
uh about what about one third comes from
the second this channel
so
uh
the probability of
being a p being a
bad hipper is about two-thirds and with
about one-half probability with signal g
so this channel offers another to about
two-thirds probability so
in other words with this randomize the
signaling scheme uh the platform
achieves a better performance
and this this example shows uh shows the
power of persuasion so what does
persuasion mean persuasion means the act
of exploiting an information advantage
in order to influence the decision of
others here the influence the
informational advantage
uh lies in the
lies in the hand of the platform the
platform knows exactly what uh the type
of p but the driver only knows the prior
distribution
and persuasion
is ubiquitous in everyday's life as the
title of a paper
american economic
review
says that one quarter of the gdp is
persuasion
and there are many real life examples
including separate cyber security
negotiation and regularization
regulation etc
and the mathematical model we consider
about of persuasion is called basic
persuasion it's pioneered by this famous
famous paper and based in persuasion is
a static game played between two players
one is called the sender and the other
one is called receiver so sender here is
just a platform receiver is a driver
which receives the signal
and sender observes
uh observes the outcome
from a prior distribution here this
outcome is whether p is a bad tipper or
a good tipper and the prior distribution
is just one-third or or two-thirds
and up upon
observing an outcome uh the sender will
send a signal to uh to the to the driver
and then to the receiver the receiver
receives a signal
and computes a posterior distribution
about the outcome
then
the receiver will take optimal uh
will be rational in the sense that it
will choose the action which maximize
the post the posterior expected utility
peer u is the utility of the drive of
the receiver
and this is a
this expectation is equal to the
posterior expected value
of the utility function if action a
prime is taken then
the receiver will choose action which
maximize this quantity
then the the sender's return is given by
uh it's got is given by the expected
totally expected reward so here sender
has another reward function which is
might be different from the utility
function of the receiver and this this
is the expected value uh
expected reward obtained by the sender
and it depends both on the uh on the
prior distribution and implicitly
depends on the signaling policy here i
say it's imp it implicitly depends on
that because the sender cannot take the
action the action is taken by the
receiver
and the goal of the
of basic persuasion is for the sender to
send a seeker to choose a signaling
policy which maximizes the sender's
sender's objective
and here our goal is to extend extend
based in persuasion to the sequential
setting because uh
the classical basic persuasion is the
static game we want to
also consider uh sequential uh
sequential changes and which is
motivated by real
right-handing systems where there are
some seasonal changes and also changes
in uh
in demand and supply through time
and also we would like to design a
probably efficient reinforcement
algorithm for solving this
and the model we we consider is called
the
markov persuasion process where which
involve a
a sender and a group of myopic receivers
and at each time
and those receivers
joins the game sequentially so at each
time a new receiver joins the game and
plays a basic persuasion problem with
with the
with the sender
and in specific the sender receives the
uh
the sender observes the outcome
and sends a signal to the receiver and
this receiver receives this signal and
takes a myopic irrational action
and then
it after taking that action the receiver
gets the immediate reward and leaves the
system
and then upon taking that action the
system
evolves into a new state according to a
markov transition kernel
and the goal of the of the sender
is to design a signaling policy which
maximizes the cumulative return obtained
by the sender
oh myopic means that upon uh the
optimization problem is
uh is exactly characterized by
by this so that means
there might be multiple receivers but
the receiver only look at the utility at
its current steps at the current
timestamp
and after taking that action that
receiver leaves a problem uh leaves the
system and and the next step and there's
another new receiver comes to the system
in the sense that he's ignoring his
impact on
just ignoring the past the past
receivers that is the receiver today
doesn't have nothing uh have no
knowledge about receivers yesterday and
and it is the distribution of actions or
signal realization in the past uh
informative
to
so the signaling are not independent it
depends on the underlying state and
outcome the outcome we are we assume
that this mu are independent uh so the
states they speaks over time is that the
assumption there is a fixed state and so
observing more signals is telling you
something about the state uh yeah yes
well
yes i know i will talk about the exact
definition in a later slide
and also for learning we consider this
online setting where we want to learn
from from interaction and for that we we
need to by interacting with the
environment we the goal is to collect a
good data set for exploration and like
and like many other
online learning problems we need to deal
with the trade-off between exploration
and exploitation
and now uh yeah going back to your
introduction to the
share rights
how does the myopic
behavior relate
oh here is uh
is what is static this this game is
static it's not now it's not a
sequential problem so that means uh you
can
for this problem uh in the signaling uh
this strategy three if you are taking
action according to this uh you are
automatically uh myopic direction
because you only look at the utility at
the current stack this is what i mean by
my
own can you give us an example of your
more general setup that's bigger
yes so consider say uh
the platform wants to maximize the
revenue or the revenue in a total month
in a whole month and when in with each
day or
or in with each week the
the demand and supply might uh might
oscillate
and also that the demand and supply
might depend on some contextual
information
like for example if it's a national
holiday then perhaps the demand is
increasing
so how is all that showing up in your
omegas
oh i will talk about this
formulation
in this the mathematic model is here
so
we consider
there are a few variables
this s is called state
and which is affected by the action
and also there's a outcome which
assembled from the prime distribution
and
i teach at each step the receiver and
the sender both
uh
both both observe the current state of
the system
and the sender
the sender observes the exact value of
the outcome but
but the receiver only knows the prior
distribution
and then the sender sends a signal
the receiver takes an action
and the state evolves into a new state
according to a markov transition kernel
but this um this omega this outcome it
doesn't it's not affected by the action
so
intuitively this can be viewed as some
uh some um
some random process or some seasonal
effect which is not affected by the
action of the
of the
of the
receiver and uh so
here what i mean is by myopic
directional action what i mean is the
receiver
observes the current state
and
receive the signal m
then it computes a posterior
distribution and choose an action which
maximizes
uh the
immediate reward obviously sorry the
immediate utility i forgot this
immediately
you
which is the same as the as in the
example yeah
so why do you need the uh to introduce
the outcome apart from the state in this
model oh the reason is
if
the state is uh well
why can't it be that the sender knows
the state but the receiver does not
but the receiver doesn't know this oh
um
then uh it's that it will become a
different model it will become a
partially absorbed mdp and the receiver
needs to infer the belief state infer
the distribution of the underlying state
it's a different problem here
we consider
uh in some sense a
an easier problem because if it's a palm
dp here that this and the sender cannot
cannot
takes action then exploration will be
very hard
here
in our setup there's a
again information advantage in the sense
that
the sender
knows
exactly what the outcome omega is
but the receiver doesn't know
and there's a misaligned objective
each send each uh each receiver joining
the game
wants to maximize the immediate reward
it's immediately to you
but the sender wants to maximize the
punitive that is there are we assume
there are capital calculation number of
steps because the episodic case
and the goal of the sender is to find a
signaling scheme which maximizes
cumulative return
for this problem um
there are a few challenges well the most
important challenge is a couple
challenge due to exploration in the
online setting and
the constraint due to basic persuasion
that is we want to ensure that the
signal is uh
we want to ensure that the signaling
scheme uh satisfy the the constraint due
to basic persuasion that is the uh the
action taken by the receiver is
posterior optional
then there are some two questions
two additional challenges compared to
standard mdp due to this persuasiveness
the first one is how do we come up with
an exploration incentive that is subject
to persuasiveness
uh that is when we want to do
exploration
because
the sender is not taking the action the
action is determined by the receiver but
still we need to uh explore the system
then how do we do this exploration
and the second question is
when there is a persuasiveness
constraint how do we maximize the policy
and here this objective depends on what
depends on the reward in you know in the
in
in a sequence
in a whole episode so it's the sum of h
reward functions and we want to maximize
this cumulative return
and in the interest of time i will skip
the
the
related work so uh for for this problem
if we know
and oh i need to mention that uh what do
we know and um
so for online learning
or what
by saying online learning we want to
design the policy for the sender
and from the perspective of cinder
cinder only observes the state outcome
and action reward
and then the sender knows uh the utility
of the receiver because it's it needs to
compute the best response of the
receiver but the sender doesn't know the
state
the reward function of sender itself and
it doesn't know the the state transition
and this is very important because if it
doesn't know the state transition it
needs to explore and it needs to explore
by incentivizing the sender to take
correct actions to export the system
and uh if we know the model then there's
uh we are able to have uh to
characterize the optional solution uh
there's a for this problem there's a
revolution principle type of result
showing that
although you can send arbitrary signal
it surfaces to just send the signal
which is
which lies in the action space that is
you can treat your signal as a
recommended action
and then given that uh by saying that
the uh the policy is
the cost of policy that is admissible is
that the the policy is incentivized uh
it's called persuasiveness that is the
policy the action recommended by the
sender
is indeed the posterior optimal
this is given by this complicated
equation but
here what is what this term is
uh is that uh this a
is the recommended action and uh it's uh
it's the
posterior uh expected returns following
this recommended action and it's better
than you
when you are recommended by a but taking
action a prime
that means always following a given this
condition holds then always following
the recommendation is optimal for the
receiver
then the optional policy
can be characterized by the by the
greedy function a greedy policy with
with respect to the action value
function here this action value function
satisfy this bellman equation which is
very similar to the classical one but
the only difference is that here taking
the greedy policy is
should be taken within the set of
persuasive policy
it depends on the both the prior
distribution and the utility function
and for uh now i would like to uh
briefly talk about this online setting
for the uh the problem we are interested
in for the sender so
in terms of online learning uh
from the perspective of cinder it just
specify a signaling policy and recommend
it to the to the receiver and collect
the new data the data in the data the
action is taken by the receiver but but
when the policy is persuasive then we
can ensure that this action is exactly
sampled from the policy
and we assume that there are t episodes
and
to characterize the performance of of
the algorithm we use the standard notion
of regret
and in addition to regret we also need
to ensure persuasiveness so that is we
want to ensure that the pi t
is always persuasive with respect to the
prior distribution and the utility
function here the prior distribution is
not known
to the to the sender
but the sender is only able to
to collect the sample from the prior
distribution
then compared to uh classical reinforced
learning the only uh well the main
additional stuff is this persuasiveness
assumption a persuasive persuasiveness
constraint it's a constraint for the
policy
so this this constraint is an integral
equation it involves the integration
with respect to the prior distribution
which is not known to the center
but we only we're only able to sample to
collect sample from the from the prior
distribution
it is it's stored in the data so how do
we
ensure persuasiveness constraint is
satisfied what we are going to do is to
use a pessimism approach that is instead
of estimating
the prior distribution derived directly
from the data
we also construct a confidence region
for this prior distribution which
which contains the prior distribution
with high probability
then
in our policy update
we update our policy
by letting it to be persuasive for all
the distribution within the set of
confidence region
so here the confidence region is given
denoted by this bt and it's it can be
computed uh estimated say using
competency ellipsoid or using a total
variation of the ball uh total variation
needs to spot from uh centered at the
empirical mean then we update the policy
using the greedy policy
with respect to the estimated q function
and subject to the persuasiveness
constraint here this persuasiveness with
respect to
all the distribution all the candidate
prior distribution within the confidence
region
then
and this q function is optimistic
estimate of the optimal queue function
and it's
to estimate this it's uh similar to
classical reinforcement algorithm like
ucb rsvi ucb
or other optimistic
reinforcement method
and this q of this
mu t is the center of the confidence
region it it can be estimated you say
using some ridge regression
and the confidence region can be
constructed using condensing episode
then with with this pessimism approach
we can ensure that with high probability
the all the policies satisfy this
persuasiveness uh
persuasiveness constraint with high
probability and more importantly what is
the price paid for achieving this
pessimism we can show that in terms of
regret the error there's the error term
shows up due to pessimism and it's up
and it's upper bounded by
uh
by the by the distance
well essentially by the width of the
confidence region
in terms of total variation distance
and this this result is obtained
assuming that the
prior distribution satisfy certain
irregularity condition the regularity
condition uh intuitively means that each
every action
can be optimal action with some margin
and with with constant probability in
some sense that means each action can be
persuaded
because just consider abundant problem
if there are some some action you will
never persuade like the i like the
receiver to take then there is no way
you can explore this action
so this
regularity condition essentially means
that all all possible actions action
sequences can be persuaded
and then for
for as what in terms of algorithm design
what i haven't talked about is how to
construct this q function
so for q function is uh it's press
standard it's constructed using
any it can be computed you construct it
using any optimistic reinforcement
algorithm and in our paper we use
lsviucb so it combines it contains two
steps the first one is to
solve a rigid regression problem and
then the second step is do some
uncertain quantification and add the
uncertainty and at
the use the width of the uncertainty
region as a bonus function and add it to
the value function construct the
optimistic one
and as for a theoretical result we
proved that
first our
theoretical results involve two aspects
the first one is that this algorithm
ensures persuasiveness with high
probability
and the second one is that it achieves
sublinear regret
and
here in the regret bound the first term
is is the same as the standard lsvi ucb
paper and there's additional term p0 and
d which comes from the regularity
assumption of the prior distribution
and in the tabular case
that is the number of outcome and state
and action are finite we can also have
this more
explicit formula and in terms of proof
technique here our additional ingredient
is just a persuasiveness
persuasiveness uh constraint
and we in a proof we derive a new
performance difference lemma that have
tailored to this persuasiveness uh
constraint and it can decompose error
into a few terms and there's a term
which only involves the persuasiveness
and it connects to the the informal
result i talk about which is the price
paid for ensuring persuasiveness
and in the interest of time i will stop
here and thank you all for for your
attention
cool thanks a lot
uh very interesting stuff so uh let's
see are there any questions right now
oh yeah acoustics
a very interesting model uh this markov
persuasive process
uh i was wondering like if you know
you know like in the background you
presented the um
standard knows the prior so i wonder
if in your case the sender knows the
prior can you come like and it's a
centralized problem can you compute the
optimal policy
uh in polynomial times
oh cinder doesn't know the prior sender
can only sample from the from the prior
now in many cases though i mean the
sender can see both the outcome and
knows the prior i mean this is i believe
even the model you started with right i
mean in the non-person in the
non-markovian
i was wondering if the center has this
extra
knowledge
like if the priorities come on knowledge
to both the sender and the receiver
right but the sender also sees the the
real estate of the world
can you compute optimal policies in
polynomial time
oh yes yes because the here if you if if
you know the prior distribution then
this you will just have a
deterministic constraint and this can
with that constraint you can use linear
program to solve the policy update
so it can be computed efficiently
let's see were there any other questions
i guess have you thought about like uh
general function approximation at all oh
yeah it's it's
it's a proof it's very modular so as
long as you can have optimistic q
function and you know how to quantify
its answer and you can do it google
uh let's see any other questions
all right if there's no more questions
we can uh go ahead and stop there
okay
uh
a little over time so why don't we maybe
take like a short five minute break and
then if people are uh interested in the
open problem session we can come back
and do that